so this is the second area base and a
lot of you a lot of you had some really
good guesses as how to do this question
but even those of you who got the right
art so we're still like yeah but not
like a hundred percent certain or I
can't convince my friends that I right
and they're wrong
okay that was a lot of conversations I
have okay so first now tell you what the
answer is and then I'll tell you how I
get it
the answer is thirty okay now that just
hey you guys do this right um would I do
this
like this is not for me I don't do this
for me I do it for you and for the
benefit of all kinds of other people
around the world don't get to sit in a
mathematics classroom like you guys do
and I've never really want to do it if I
have to edit out fifteen times but I
just have to stop and look at people and
then proceed so it's really up to you I
I gain nothing from having to explain
this to you because I have all the
artists myself I just I know what I
don't feel like when I get frustrated
when I don't know how something works I
just need someone to give me a hand okay
so I'm gonna ask you to be courteous to
your peers who actually are interested
in this or excuse yourself from the
classroom it's a simple choice alright
let's try again let me get rid of this
editor and I'll show you how I reasoned
through get into the area of that little
rectangle over in the bottom right hand
corner okay now this is tricky this one
because unlike the first one I showed
you over here right where you saw your
over this forty two remember this forty
two we saw it was seven by six so you
can do your times tables for that that's
pretty good but then you get to this guy
and the first number you encounter is 13
and 13 a bit of a jerk right because 13
has what factors 13 and 1 and you're
like ah you can deal with decimals or
you could deal with fractions but you
don't have to and you shouldn't
- there are other ways to do this so
here's what I did remember what we were
like oh I don't know what a number is so
I'm going to use algebra because algebra
helps me work with numbers even when I
don't know what their values are okay so
this rectangle over here at the top left
I'm gonna say maybe it's a set of
readers from top to bottom top to bottom
and maybe we'll call it B centimeters
from left to right okay
a times B now because you guys have done
measurement before you've done
rectangles so you know if you've got a
height and a width you can say whatever
these might happen to be the a times B
that's got to be 13 okay I don't know
what they are but I don't need to okay
now once you have a look over to the
right of the diagram do you see you got
this other rectangle over here this one
this with you okay I don't know how wide
it is do you see how I know that there's
this with over here but this one is
different and I don't know what it is
okay but look at the height I actually
do know how high it is
right cuz I already gave that a name I
called that a right so just like it's
over here it must be a up and down like
this okay
now what's this guy over here what is
this I'll just put a question mark there
for a moment okay well just like I said
a times B is 13 this height and this
width on this rectangle over on the
right a times whatever it's gonna be 26
do you agree with that now have a look
have a look if you compare this equation
and this equation you can see 30 - 26
that's not a coincidence
those numbers aren't just like randomly
13 to 26 26 is exactly double it's
exactly two times right so that means
that remember I didn't know what the
width was well actually I do know what
the width is the width is just double
whatever the other width was okay does
that make sense to be I don't know what
B is but I don't need to okay so I'm
gonna say right this guy over here is to
be from left to right
okay now that's what I know I'm gonna
move into what I don't know okay uh this
height over here at the bottom I don't
know what this is Eva I really don't so
I'm just gonna give it another name I'm
going to call it C right now at C times
the same width over here B times C that
will give you the area which is 15 right
so now have a look at the unknown I'm
finally there right I know what its
height is C and I just now worked out
how wide it was which is to be do you
see that to be okay
so the area of a rectangle is its width
times its height and that B times C I
already know what that is it's 15 so
that's why it's 2 times 50 which is the
30 that a lot of you worked out okay so
you can see there was no there were no
pretty rules or anything like that in
the earlier part of the question boys
can just wait outside for me just step
outside and I'll speak to you afterwards
they can you you can see there was no
algebra in the question like the
question didn't say hey use algebra to
solve me but algebra is great you should
use it whenever you can to help you
solve questions like this okay it's very
very hidden all right let's have a look
at number three this one doesn't require
any algebra let me show you how I
approached it some of you I gave a clue
to this is the clue I gave I drew a line
down like that and a line across so I
made this new rectangle over there on
the left hand side okay I'm a
highlighter for you see this rectangle I
think you should be able to tell me how
big it is
can you tell me it area it's yeah it's
18 square centimeters where does the 18
come from yeah it's rude yeah very good
you can see this six comes across all
the way from the right to the left okay
so that makes this guy 18 square
centimeters okay but that means if I
like join another vertical line
like this have a look you can see on the
right of the diagram I've got another
rectangle that I know the area of let me
highlight it for you see this one this
one in red what's the area of this
rectangle yeah 1824 and you can see it's
just the 4x6 right 24 square centimeters
now that looks like an Italian flag
what's that white pot in the middle
that's just the lost leftover bit can
you tell me how to work it out know how
to be required have a look yeah yeah 43
minus 24 is exactly right because 43 is
that whole rectangle and we just we just
cut out that red bit right 43 minus 24
that's that's 19 right 19 okay now
what's really lovely about having all
these numbers now is if I put in an
outline like this this rectangle here
now I know how big that rectangle is
right because I've got the left-hand
side which is green and I've got the
right-hand side which is why so the
purple rectangle is 18 plus 13 which is
37 right but that's the same as the
rectangle at the top they're the same
area and look they're the same width
do you see that so if they're the same
area and then the same width what does
that mean about the heights the heights
are also identical right um they're
they're actually what we call Col Gruen
figures because they're identical
they've just been moved up and down so
that's a six and that's a six there so
that's the nice easy one okay all right
last one let's have a look did anyone
get this one here we get it okay it's
pretty it's pretty tricky I'll see if I
all need to work hard to see if I could
remember it okay so have a look um okay
where did I start okay yes I remember
all right have a look if you have it if
you have a look at this diagram and you
have a look at these little links that
have been put on either side of things
right for instance you got this this
four over here right but that tells you
what this distance is do you notice that
that tells you that the little distance
must be two because four and two they
give you six right does that make sense
by the same logic if you have a look
down here right you know how much that
little like this too right it also
happens to be two because same logic in
fact two plus three that's what gives
you the five okay now hold on a second
just look just compare now let me
highlight for you compare this yellow
rectangle here
with the grey rectangle that's on the
right can you see that okay because each
of them has chopped off the same amount
here and here right do you see they're
actually the same height they've just
been slid up and down right ones going
to up that one's going to down do you
see that okay so therefore whatever this
height is is going to be the same as
this height over here they've just been
moved up and down from each other okay
can you see where you can go next have a
look what else can you use you hmm
Kenny one Toby what is the width of that
rectangle up there a lot of you who have
just written that down pretty quickly
how do you work out that width yeah yeah
I think it's 13 as well how did we find
out it was 13 yeah yeah very good
six times 13 must give you the area so
78 divided by six gives you 13 that's
the team what about this one down here
what's the width of this guy it's also
gonna be that's not a coincidence is it
it's also gonna be 13 because 5 times 13
is 65 okay so now that tells you those
two rectangles are the same width that
means I need a new color that means this
distance here and this distance here
also the same because they've just been
moved one to the left and one to the
right okay so whatever this is and
whatever this this is there
identical there's two green legs okay so
we just worked out yellow and gray right
Heights are the same width to the same
so I don't need to know what the height
and width are I just need to know
they're identical so it's 50 as well
okay